foreign
World cyber security is vital in
safeguarding sensitive information
critical infrastructure and personal
data from unauthorized access misuse and
malicious activities IT addresses the
increasing prevalence of cyber threats
including data breaches and ransomware
attacks which pose risk to individual
organizations and economics moreover
cyber security is essential for
maintaining trust in digital
Technologies and protecting online
transactions intellectual properties and
individual privacy as a result the
increasing demand for cyber security
expert is apparent and projected to grow
in the coming years as this demand
expand a wide range of career prospects
in the cyber security field become
available to individuals with various
backgrounds and skill sets some of the
roles in this domain include security
analyst cryptographers and Security
Consultants based on the data from
Glassdoor the average annual salary for
cyber Security Professionals in the
United States is approximately 92 000 in
India the average annual salary is 12
lakh some well-known companies hire
cyber Security Professionals including
American Express Netflix Oracle Amazon
LinkedIn Microsoft Google and VMware
however it's worth noting that there are
numerous other companies both large and
small across various industries that
also hire cyber security experts on that
note hello everyone and welcome to
Simply learns YouTube channel this video
will dive into an insightful discussion
on the top cyber security boot camp for
2023. two embark on a successful career
in cyber security a blend of technical
skills knowledge and specific personal
qualities is essential the following are
critical skills and attributes that hold
significant value for individual
aspiring to enter cyber security first
it is essential to occur knowledge of
computer systems specifically how they
operate including Hardware software
protocols and networks next after
gaining knowledge of computer systems it
is essential to focus on network
security this involves learning about
Network architecture fairwalls ideas
virtual private networks and other
network security Technologies then once
you have developed an understanding of
network security it is crucial to focus
on programming and scripting acquired
programming skills in languages like
python C plus plus and Java or scripting
languages like Powershell and Bash which
can be used for automation analysis and
developing security tools focus on
vulnerability assessment and iteration
testing it is crucial to learn how to
identify and exploit vulnerabilities in
systems and networks and conduct ethical
hacking to assist and enhance security
then cryptography familiarize yourself
with encryption algorithms cryptographic
protocols and their applications in
securing data and Communications
additionally skills that are important
to have an understanding include
operating systems secure coding
effective communication and teamwork
analytical and problem solving skills
and a commitment to continuous learning
building a solid foundation in this
skills will provide a strong starting
point for your journey to become a cyber
security professional moreover staying
up to date with cyber security
advancements and regularly updating
security measure is crucial for
individuals and organizations to ensure
optimal protection against cyber threats
with that in mind and work on the
journey as a cyber Security
Professionals with the Caltech cyber
security bootcamp acquire the skills and
practical experience necessary to
safeguard critical systems and sensitive
data from cyber attacks all through
engaging in real world projects with
this caltex cyber security bootcamp
enhance your Proficiency in defensive
and offensive cyber security digital
forensic penetration testing
infrastructure design and other
essential areas our comprehensive
curriculum Hands-On labs and guided
practices provide exposure to a wide
range of in-demand cyber security tools
as you progress through the course you
will follow a comprehensive learning
path that includes fundamental cyber
security Concepts Network systems Python
Programming system administrations and
offensive security and defensive
security practices Additionally you will
gain hands-on experience through
multiple projects in sandbox Labs
ensuring that you emerge as a standout
industry ready cyber security
professional the course covers many
essential skills including network
security risk management threat analysis
data privacy and security digital
forensic Incident Management data
privacy identity management and many
more along with the skills the course
also covers various tools and
Technologies such as python Linux and
many more also embark on exciting
industry projects that provide hands-on
experience and practical insights so
hurry up and find the course Link in the
description box for more details our
Learners have experienced two success in
their career listen to their experience
find the simply Course Review Link in
the description box the next cohort is
starting soon to know more about this
intensive training program which impacts
job ready skills and prepares you for a
career as a cyber security expert check
out the link below in the description
box with this we have come to the end of
this with cyber security boot camp for
2023 if you like this video subscribe to
our YouTube channel and hit the Bell
icon to never miss any updates from
Simply learn if you need any help opting
for this course please let us know in
the comment section below we will get
back to you as soon as possible until
next time thank you stay safe and keep
learning
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here